[Musique]
le Grand Jury RTL le Figaro LCI invité
aujourd'hui François Baou maire de Po et
président du MoDem le débat est dirigé
par Benjamin
sportouche bonjour à tous bienvenue dans
ce grand jury bonjour François Baou
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
en ce 1er mai vous faites d'exception à
ce jour il y a beaucoup de candidats en
liste pour la présidentielle de 2017
vous ne l'êtes pas alors que votre
décision est prise à 100% nous en
parlerons mais avant cela nous vous
interrogerons sur la situation
économique du pays le président de la
République dit que ça va mieux les
chiffres en ont attester cette semaine
pour parti en tous les cas vous nous
direz si c'est votre avis ou pas si vous
lui décernez un satisfait site et puis
la loiel comery hein sur le travail elle
est discutée à partir de mardi à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez est-ce que vous vous la
voteriez si vous étiez député quelles
sont vos propositions pour redresser la
France beaucoup de questions à vous
poser donc aujourd'hui et pour
m'accompagné Guillaume roquet directeur
du Figaro Magazine et Christophe
jacubissine TF1 LCI sont à mes côtés et
puis vous savez que le Grand Jury est
une émission interactive et que les
auditeurs les téléspectateurs peuvent
vous poser des questions réagir sur
Twitter et c'est Benoît galeré de TF1
LCI qui nous rejoindra en fin d'émission
pour nous parler de ces questions nous
les transmettre alors benoî bonjour
comment c fonctionne comment font nos
amis téléspectateurs et auditeurs pour
réagir et bien vous utilisez votre
compte Twitter si vous en avez un avec
le hashtag ler jury tout attaché
n'hésitez pas non plus à suivre le
compte officiel le Grand Jury il y a les
principales déclarations de nos invités
vous pouvez en effet réagir et je
viendrai vous résumer tout ça en fin
d'émission à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure benoî donc hashtag le Grand Jury
vous êtes vous-même un grand utilisateur
des réseaux sociaux monsieur Baayou il
me semble alors j'ai j'ai 400
700onn aute twitterant il y a quelques
Ann je souviens ttter dit comment
voulez-vous je résume ma pensée en
140 aujourd'hui mais de manière concise
parce que nous avons beaucoup de
questions à vous poser et la première
monsieur Baou en ce 1er mai il y a des
défilés qui vont avoir lieu cet
après-midi des violences ont eu lieu
jeudi est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement a toujours la maîtrise de
la situation est-ce qu'il est
responsable de ce qui s'est passé jeudi
il a une part très importante de
responsabilité et les Français le
ressentent très bien c'est le maintien
de la sécurité et d'un ordre minimal
dans la ville
et une intervention qui doit
être solide non pas agressive mais
solide pour empêcher tout débordement
que ce soit il a failli ou pas est-ce
que il n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait on
voit bien que le gouvernement essaie de
ménager j'ai
cette cette partie de l'opinion
représentée par ceux qui
manifeste il est de mais il est
responsable de l'ordre public il peut
pas se débarrasser de cette
responsabilité il peut pas éluder cette
responsabilitéut dire pour des raisons
politiques il n pas assumé cette
responsabilité TR j'étais hier soir
autour de la place de la République avec
certains de mes enfants qu' avit un
concert très sympathique il y avait un
concert sympathique et il y a beaucoup
gens aussi extrêmement irrités vous P fa
donc et donc la responsabilité du
gouvernement c'est naturellement de
défendre le droit de manifester c'est un
droit constitutionnel mais de faire il y
a deux mouvements il y a les
manifestations effectivement classique
et puis il y a nuit debout place de la
République dans un certain nombre de
villes de province aussi qui sont des
mouvements permanents même si il lève le
camp entre 1h du matin et le matin y
compris à est-ce qu'il faut fermer ce
est-ce qu'il faut interdire est-ce qu'il
faut évacuer ce type de de de de point
de fixation comme il y en a place de la
République à Paris écoutez c'est très
simple ou bien c'est violent et agressif
et ça et c'est un mouvement qui s'en
prend au bien aux personnes parfois et
il faut à ce momentlà dire non ou bien
c'est un mouvement qui n'a pas de
violence et qui est simplement une
manifestation et à ce
momentl on a le devoir de protéger
est-ce que vous estimez maintenant qu'il
y a un mois que nu Debou est présent en
place de la République en plein cœur de
Paris est-ce que vous dites maintenant
on les a entendu ou est-ce que vous
pensez que le mouvement peut prospérer à
cet endroit-là je ne suis pas sûr que le
mouvement puisse prospérer tout court
pourquoi euh
pour une raison très simple c'est que il
y a pas de débouché politique ou
réaliste visible
c'est une protestation qui se veut une
protestation sans but c'est le
l'affirmation disent un changement de
société un changement de mode de
pratique de gouvernance ou je je suis
comme vous l'affirmation des
organisateurs de la
manifestation c'est que ils n'ont pas de
demande à présenter ils n'ont pas de but
la seule qu'ils ont présenté si j'ai
bien compris c'est l'inscription de la
langue des signes dans la Constitution
ce qui évidemment ne touche pas et la
semaine de 25h aussi oui et
donc c'est un mouvement qui qui a des
aspects très idéalistes d'autres qui
sont très comment
dire
irréaliste mais sans débouché mais sans
débouché et comme il n'y a pas débouché
je ne crois pas que le mouvement puisse
prendre de l'ampleur qu'il y est qu'il y
est dans la société
française une très grande insatisfaction
qui a beaucoup de visages tous reliés
entre eux social
écologique
économique culturel c'est c'est un fait
d'évidence on va en parler pendant toute
cette émission les gens ressentent une
frustration et à juste titre à mon avis
d'un pays qui n'est pas gouverné comme
il devrait l'être d'un pays qui ne qui
n'a pas de but qui n'a pas de cap et
donc c'est très profond mais que des
mouvements sporadiques
puissent exprimer mais il expriment
aussi la défiance qu'on les Français
vis-à-vis des politiques à nuit debout
moi j'ai quandême question vous n avez
dit à 3 minutes que vous avez fait nuit
Debou hier vous êtes allé place de la
République est-ce que vous étieztiz RZ
pas écout la question c'est est-ce que
c'est pas une d'allerb je suis allé
manger un morceau avec certains de mes
enfants à quelques 500 m de la place ré
pas symptomatique de la défiance des
Français vis-à-vis des politiques pour
vous nuit
debout c'est symptomatique du malaise
d'un certain nombre de Français face à
la société et à ceux qui
conduisent cette société là mais je ne
crois pas que ce cela est un grand écho
dans l'opinion je ne crois pas que ce
soit très suivi et je ne crois pas
surtout que ça puisse conduire un
mouvement parce que il n'y a pas de cap
il y a pas de débouché politique on voit
pas où il veir non plus ouais alors ils
en font une fierté de ne pas avoir de
chef mais il n'y a pas de direction
d'accord sur certains disent aujourd'hui
que l'État urgence étant en vigueur ce
genre de manifestation ne devrait pas
avoir lieu est-ce que vous estimez-vous
que l'état d'urgence doit être prolongé
à nouveau comme le gouvernement l'a
annoncé le frera est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est une une atteinte aux libertés
j'ai toujours pensé qu'il le ferait et
je ne crois pas que ce soit une attete
aux liberté donc il faut le maintenir et
et on peut parfaitement vivre avec un
état d'urgence qui permet aux citoyens
d'exprimer leurs sentiments si on est
dans le cadre du respect des autres et
de la loi jusqu'à quand l'état d'urgence
monsieur Baayou est-ce que ça moi je
pense que ça ira au-delà de l'euro ça va
aller jusqu'à la rentrée ça ira jusqu'au
moment où enfin auront été voté les
dispositions qui permettent à la
puissance publique d'intervenir pour
lutter contre le terrorisme dans le
cadre de la loi ordinaire euh ces
dispositions ne sont pas votées c'est
parce qu'elles ne sont pas votées que
dans l'état d'urgence j'aurais pour ma
part souhaité que l'état d'urgence soit
constitutionnalisé parce que ça manque
dans la constitutionm
le président de la République a renoncé
à le faire en fait je ne comprends pas
très bien pourquoi parce que sur l'état
d'urgence il aurait une majorité donc
vous auriez souhaité qu'il y ait un
congrès pour l'état d'urgence je trouve
que ça aurait été bien parce que ce qui
est inscrit dans la Constitution
c'est-à-dire d'un côté l'article 16 avec
les pleins pouvoirs et de l'autre l'état
de siège ne correspond pas aux besoins
juridique au
besoins de protection de la société
contre ces actes terroristes sur la loi
comerie Christophe jacubicine puisque
beaucoup des manifestants la nuit de
nuit debout sont contre la loi de de
travail qui va réformer le code du
travail c'est l'une des principales
revendications qui expriment Christopher
cubissine oui juste d'ailleurs une demi
question là est-ce que du coup par
rapport à ce que vous vez nous dire sur
sur les ces mouvements sans sans but
est-ce qu'ils se sont des écervelés
comme l'a dit Nicolas
Sarkozi je j'emploie pas des mots comme
ça donc sur la comery c'était au départ
une c'est euh vous comprenez le le
croire qu'on est le seul à avoir de la
cervelle et que le reste des neurones
comme il dit et que le reste de la
société est
complètement à côté de la plaque et
dément au fond ou absence
de
conscience ça me paraît trop trop s ça
confirme votre jugement sur Nicolas
Sarkozi écoutez je j'exprime mon
jugement sur Nicolas Sarkozy sans
précaution j'ai écrit quand il était au
pouvoir un livre dont dont PIR but de
pouvoir dont un certain nombre de
Français se souviennent je l'ai fait
alors qu'il était au sommet de l'État
mais je ne je ne fais pas de fixation
sur Nicolas sarz pas un seul mot de ce
livre aujourd'hui monsieur qui é très
sévère pas un mot de ce livre sur
l'exercice du pouvoir par Nicolas
Sarkozy je veux vous rappeler
que c'est un livre qui parle du projet
de société que Nicolas Sarkozy était à
cette époque en train de conduire et qui
était un projet qui cultivait l'idée que
il fallait favoriser les inégalités ou
accepter les inégalités et la question
des inégalités est une question très
importante en France et dans le monde et
et je ne participe pas au mouvement de
ceux qui pensent que les illégalités
sont un plus point sur lequel vous étiez
peut-être d'accord avec Nicolas Sarkozi
dans le travailler plus pour gagner plus
dans la loi comerie il y a un projet qui
prévoit que il y a un article pardon que
les heures supplémentaires seront bien
moins rémunéré qu'aujourd'hui c'estàd 10
% de plus c'est pas 25% de plus c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles je ne
l'aurais voté en aucun cas et pourtant
le meddef dit le travail coûte trop cher
dans ce pays alors ceci est une autre
question entre le coût du travail non
c'est pas lié c'est lié parce qu'on veut
le lier mais entre le coût du travail et
ce que le travail rapporte au salarié
pardonnez-moi de dire qu'il y a une
différence considérable donc il faut
baisser les charges mais pas les salair
net je pense légitime qu'on dise il ne
faut pas que les heures supplémentaires
soit trop pénalisante pour l'entreprise
mais je pense tout aussi légitime qu'on
dise il faut que les heures
supplémentaires rapportent au salariés
beaucoup plus que leure normal c'est le
travailler plus pour gagner plus de 2007
et c'est l'onération de Ch soci fisc
trve il se trouve que j'ai toujours
défendu cette idée vous trouverez des
hein ma thèse
étant celle-ci il faut que l'heure
supplémentaire rapporte 25 % de plus au
salariés qu'une heure normale mais on
peut défalquer cette prime pour heur
supplémentairire des charges sur l'heure
supplémentaire c'est-à-dire vous vous
vous payez la prime mais cette prime
elle est euh elle est pas payée par
l'employeur elle est payée par le
contribuable pourquoi le contribuable
parce si vous baissz les pas perdre nos
auditeurs téléspectateurs ne sont
pas plus 25% non il faut employer les
mots précis euh euh elle est pas payée
par le contribuable euh il s'agit de
l'assurance sociales c'est ça les
charges
hein on considère et non mais j'ai pas
parlé d'exonération d'impôt pour ma part
de charge sociale euh de charge social
on considère simplement que la personne
qui a travaillé 35 he elle a payé sa
part de l'assurance sociale d'accord et
que pour les heures supplémentaires on
peut considérer que elle paie un peu
moins sur leur supplémentaire ce qui
fait que leur supplémentaire à
l'entreprise ne coûte pas plus cher mais
au salariés rapporte 25 % je trouve
qu'il faut payer le travail je pense
qu'on je pense pardonnez-moi c'est pas
un geste impérieux non non pas ça je
pense qu'on se trompe euh en voulant
souspayer le travail je pense que c'est
une tendance très répandu h et je pense
que c'est une tendance néfaste je pense
que le travail en France est trop peu
payé et donc il coûte beaucoup trop cher
à l'entreprise mais il est trop peu pay
entendu sur ce point fr un autre point
la surtaxation des CDD vous êtes hostile
à cela est-ce que ce n'est pas aussi un
impératif que de lutter contre la
précarité du travail puisque 90 %
aujourd'hui des embauches se font en
CDD la priorité des priorités c'est
qu'il y ait des contrats de travail et
l'idée que en surtaxant les CDD vous
indiquer que ça représente 90 % des
embauches on on va favoriser le CDI
c'est à mon avis ne rien comprendre à la
manière dont on conduit une entreprise
et dont on embauche euh le le on
embauche en CDD souvent parce que on
craint le CDI si on avait assoupli le
CDI vous savez que je défends depuis
très longtemps un CDI à droit progressif
idée qui a été reprise par mattho Renzi
en Italie et qui a créé plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'emploi en
quelques mois cette idée-là qui n'est
pas facile à faire passer on le voit
bien étant donné l'état de l'opinion un
nouveau contrat qui ne se substitue pas
aux autres mais qui se
propose autre chose ce contrat-là je
suis persuadé qu'il permettrait de créer
beaucoup plus de CDI mais surtaxer le
CDD c'est exactement le contraire
exactement le le de ce qu'il faudrait
faire et de ce que vous feriez si vous
étiez responsabilité de ce que G
gouvernement avait annoncé parce que je
vous rappelle que on a fait la loi il a
trop cédé au vous pensez qu'il a trop
cédé le gouvernement sur cette FO il
s'est il a trahi lui-même les intentions
qu'il affichait parce qu'il a dit on va
faire un droit du travail plus souple et
un travail moins cher moins lourd pour
l'entreprise et on se retrouve avec plus
de rigidité et un coup du travailug une
lo de gauche plus une lo de droite la
loi comerie aujourd'hui non c'est une
loi
ce ces dispositions là sont absurdes ces
dispositionsl sont le contraire de ce
que en tout cas pour ma part je pense
nécessaire parce que le gouvernement
sent bien que les Français ne sont pas
prêts à à à lâcher du lest là-dessus ils
sont favorables au CDI ils ont peur
parce que c'est la crise est-ce qu'on
peut vraiment honnêtement aujourd'hui
assouplir le droit du travail quand le
niveau du chômage est à ce point
euh je pense si on que si on veut que le
chômage baisse il faut assouplir le
droit du travail
euh assouplir non pas en pénalisant le
salarié mais en permettant tout
simplement que le jeu normal de la
création d'emploi de la prise de risque
de la conclusion qu'on tire si ça marche
pas que tout cela marche et soit accepté
par ce n'est pas une première étape qui
est faite dans cette loi pourquoi la
rejeté la refuser alors que la droite ne
l'a pas fait auparavant est-ce que vous
ne pouvez pas considérer que c'est une
première étape pour aller plus loin
est-ce que vous voulez bien entendre
monsieur sportouche quelque chose de
simple
j'ai approuvé les premières intentions
de la loi mais quand le gouvernement
abandonne les intentions de la loi pour
faire le contraire alors je reste fidèle
à ma ligne et je dis ça ne va pas et
donc je ne l'approuve pas le
gouvernement vous lu demandez lu reprz
de ne pas faire assez mais il fait quand
même voilà la question qu'on se POS il
fait le contraire de ce que je pense
nécessaire de faire le gouvernement en
surtaxant les CD
en abaissant le le revenu que les aires
supplémentaires rapportent au salariés
fait le contraire de ce que je crois
nécessaire de faire je pense qu'il faut
un travail plus souple et mieux payé et
ils font un travail plus rigide et plus
mal payé je regrette je suis en
désaccord avec ça le le je trouve que
cette désinvolture à l'égard des gens
qui travaillent est quelque chose de
profondément choquant c'est des
involtures aussi à l'égard des
entreprises mais c'est des involtures à
l'égard des gens qui travaillent le le
le l'idée que faudrait toujours payer
moins qui a au fond été d'une manière ou
d'une autre
euh intégré par le gouvernement elle a
infusé dans la pensée du gouvernement
cette idée n'est pas la M c'est parce
que vous avez une vision assez très
libérale de l'économie monsieur bairou
visiblement en tous les cas les français
eux expriment à chaque fois leur
défiance leur méfiance vis-à-vis du
libéralisme encore aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous êtes pas en décalage
avec je vois pas ce que vous appelez
libéralisme dans ce que je dis disIl
faut
payer c'est pas du tout ce que je vais
dire mais j'y viens dans une seconde
quand je dis il faut payer les heures
supplémentaire un bon prix certes mais
pas la surtaxation des CDD vous n pas
vous avez vous avez compris que c'est
important surtaxer les CDD enfin
apporter une surtaxation de plus parce
qu'il y a déjà une surtaxation sur les
CDD je trouve que ça va exactement à
l'encontre de ce qu'il faut obtenir et
donc je défend christop jaubisine va
interpréter ma pensée exactement dans un
sondage aujourd'hui on voit que 70 % des
Français estiment que la lutte des
classes est une réalité est-ce que vous
pensez que face à un peuple qui pense ça
on peut expliquer quand on révise ou
quand on réforme l' du travail dans un
sens plus flexible ce n'est pas contre
les salarés question posez-moi la
question je vouis je voulais bien vous
la poser non non non demandez-moi à moi
si la lutte des classes est une réalité
est elle est une réalité donc vous êtes
comme 72 % des Français vous pensez
qu'elle existe et queah écoutez j'ai les
yeux ouverts sur le monde donc François
Baou est un marxiste
pas du tout je je suis je vois
exactement je vois exactement ce qu'il
en est dans une société en plus une
société qui se durcit qui s'enquiste
dans laquelle il y
a en
effet
des recherche de privilèges et de
défense des privilège et volonté de
faire que le pouvoir et l'avoir soit
concentré dans les même m euh vous savez
socialiste en 2012 on vous sait
maintenant marxiste mais mais c'est
c'est intéressant ce que vous ça ve
dire peut-être pour vous ça vous fait
rire mais pour moi non non ça me fait
pas rire c'est pour moi je considère que
c'est une des faiblesses de la société
française que de ne pas être arrivé
parvenu à une société dans laquelle
l'ascenseur social marche bien dans
laquelle on peut faire des études mais
même quand on vient des milieux les plus
difficiles dans laquelle on peut espérer
avoir des
situations d'influence ou des situations
de
de de bien-être même quand on vient de
loin dans la société même quand on est
pasé né dans les milieux oass elle est
pas entre patron et salariés elle est
plutôt entre ceux qui sont dans le
système et ceux qui n sont pas entiers
et ceux qui qui sont pas en gros oui
c'est c'est il y a en effet une une
exclusion
de millions de français et de leurs
enfants des situations qui sont les
nôtres les vôtres les et autrefois on
pouvait il y a quelques décennies on
pouvait faire le chemin on pouvait venir
de de du Berne profond et du pied des
Pyrénées de milieu qui étaient des
milieux sans argent et faire le
chemin et on y arrivait parce que
l'école offrait ça aujourd'hui on n'y
arrive plus alors je considère que oui
en effet cet état de la société décptage
cette analyse n'est pas en général
partager à droite c'est juste ça e ben
peut-être ça vous expliquera
pourquoi pourquoi je défends l'idée euh
qu'il faut une proposition politique
différente et cette proposition
politique différente je l'appelle centre
pour des raisons qui peut-être sont
méritent d'être défendu tout le monde se
dit centriste aujourd'hui ça me fait
rire parfois mais en tout cas ce euh
l'idée qu'on a besoin de démocratiser la
société au sens où on a besoin d'égalité
des chances l'idée qu'on a besoin
d'ouvrir les situations de pouvoir et
d'influence et pas qu'elle soit réservée
uniquement au fils et filles de cette
idée là est la mienne je l'ai toujours
défendu pour des raisons personnelles
historiques que vous comprendrez et je
la défends parce que le les
familles qui qui sont dans cette
situation situation d'exclusion je
considère que j'en ai la charge je
considère quesur c'est
mon c'est ma vocation et ma
mission de de prendre parti pour elle et
de défendre leurs enfants alors que
personne ne les défend plus est-ce que
vous pensez justement monsieur Baayou
que ces gens que vous défendez que vous
dites défendre sont d'accord avec cette
augmentation du salaire du patron de
Carlos Gon c'est aussi dans l'idée de
cette lutte des des classe dont les
Français nous disent aujourd'hui qu'elle
existe encore est-ce que vous êtes
choqué est-ce que vous trouvez indécent
que le patron de Renault Carlos Gon soit
augmenté alors même que l'assemblée
générale dont l'état est membre a émis
un avis défavorable je trouve que ce
sont des salaires
indesscent euh le ce ce monsieur-là euh
euh Carlos il gagnera pour Renault
euh 7 millions et quelques
7251000 et pour Nissan
8 millions et quelques ça fait 15
millions dans l'année et je considère
que ce sont des salaires qui ne
reflètent pas en rien le service que on
peut qu'on rend à la société parce
qu'après tout le salaire c'est c'est ça
hein c'est c'est la contrepartie du
service que vous rendez donc je suis en
désaccord avec ces Sal et je pense que
ça pose une question fondamental de la
conception de l'entreprise je croyais
moi que
l'entreprise capitaliste dans le
capitalisme ça appartenait aux
actionnaires mais ça c'est un jugement
moral parfaement estimable mais en même
temps vous ne pouvez pas limiter les les
les les salaires des patrons des
entreprises privé en l'occurrence c'est
le conseil d'administration qui décide
il était d'accord ça ça vous dites ça
comme ça au passage
monsieur administration qui existe
excusez-moi il y a une assemblée
générale des actionnaires l'assemblée
générale des actionnaires a voté contre
à près de 5 re av cons et donc je trouve
que il y a quelques oui il y a un
malaise profond quand le conseil
d'administration fondé sur des je vais
essayer d'employer le mot le plus soft
possible fondé sur
des amitiés des bonnes ententes des
connivance
parfois décide d'aller à l'encontre de
l'assemblée générale des actionnaires
alors il nous reste peu de temps avant
la pause euh le Nissan le groupe Reno
Nissan fait des bénéfices importants il
c'est les ind ça fait partie des
indicateurs positifs de l'économie
française est-ce que vous pensez
François Baayou que l'économie française
va mieux comme le président l'a dit et
comme l'atteste certains chiffres de
cette semaine et notamment la baisse du
chômage oui enfin la baisse du chômage
je vous rappelle que le chômage le mois
précédent augmenté de 26000 ce mois-ci
on dit qu'il est moins 60000 j'ai eu la
curiosité j'ai eu la curiosité de
regarder le la baisse mensuelle du
chômage après on verra les mois qui
viennent c'est pour moitié des
radiations des gens qui soit sont pas
réinscrits soit qu'on a radié et pour
moitié des stages financés par l'État
alors je sais très bien que c'est pour
ça qu'on a voulu faire les stages pour
que pour que les statistiques
s'améliorent à la fin mais je ne crois
pas moi qu'il ait une amélioration
durable de la situation de l'emploi
comme on essaie de nous le faire VO même
si la consommation repart même si
l'investisur les entreprises repart
c'est autre chose là vous m'interrogez
maintenant sur l'état de l'économie je
pense que l'état de
l'économie un peu meilleur un peu
meilleur je vous rappelle que la France
est toujours derrière les autres
heélioration dans cette
amélioration et donc l'état cette
amélioration apparente et peut-être
passagère de l'état de l'économie elle
vient de deux facteurs le premier
facteur c'est la baisse du prix du
pétrole qui est qui ne présente pas que
des avantages mais du point de vue de de
la vitalité de l'économie ça paraît
mieux et le deuxième facteur c'est la
politique de Monsieur dragy à la tête de
la Banque centrale européenne qui a en
apportant des
possibilités
de de monnaie supplémenta en créant de
la monnaie oui c'est MOS Simp que ça
mais enfin c est-ce qu'il y a pas une
critique permanente aussi du pouvoir
vous vous avez été aux affaires est-ce
que vous avez pas l'impression qu'en
France aussi en permanence il y a une
dévalorisation de ce que font les
politiques au pouvoir est-ce qu'il n'y a
pas ce bashing dont on parle en
permanence et même quand il y a des bons
résultats on ne s'en satisfait pas
est-ce que vous n'allez pas à l'encontre
de ce que vous incarnez vous-même par si
ces bons résultats était dû à la
politique du gouvernement je le dirais
ce n'est pas le cas et je n'ai jamais
manqué de le dire mais ces résultats
sont principalement dû et il est juste
de le dire parce
que on critique très souvent les
institutions européennes c'est la Banque
centrale européenne qui par une action
déterminée peut-être qu'on pourrait
aller encore plus loin depuis 2 ans
comme la banque centrale américaine l'a
fait comme la Banque centrale du Japon a
essayé de le faire en apportant de
l'oxygène sous forme de monnaie
supplémentaire a permis à l'économie
européenne d'aller un peu mieux et
donc la Banque centrale européenne et
Mario Draghi méritent qu'on dise que
pour une fois alors là il y a une action
qui est une action qui sert la société
européenne très rapidement avant la
pause est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
l'ugmentation de la prime des
enseignants du primaire vous avez été
ministre de l'éducation nationale le le
le gouvernement vient de l'annoncer
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il le faut
très rapidement la par je je pense que
les enseignants français sont mal payés
plus mal payés que les autres mais je
voudrais bien que le gouvernement me
disent d'où il tire cet argent donc vous
ne souhaitez pas si si j'additionne euh
les les annonces qui ont été faites
depuis un mois vous avez tous les jours
300 millions ici 800 millions là 3
milliards
pourend ce
calulard 550 millions ici et si vous
faites les additions vous vous dites
mais ces gensl en réalité sur quel
compte tirentil leur ch alors on en
parle juste après la pause on se
retrouve pour votre grand jury à 13h3
dans 3 minutes après
[Musique]
titre suite du Grand Jury RTL le Figaro
LCI invité aujourd'hui François Baayou
maire de pot et président du MoDem le
débat est dirigé par Benjamin sportouche
alors François baayrou juste avant la
pause nous parlions de la prime des
enseignants du primaire qui va être
augmentée vous nous dit disiez que vous
interrogiez sur le le budget sur lequel
cette cette prime sera prélevée est-ce
que vous pensez qu'il y a du
clientélisme électoral
oui je pense que depuis des semaines a
commencé la grande opération
clientéliste qui consiste à essayer de
récupérer catégorie par catégorie les
voix des uns et des autres en signant
des chècs dont on n'a pas évidemment le
premier euro sur son comp l'augmentation
du point d' fonctionnaire l'augmentation
du point d'indice pour la fonction
publique c'est une mesure clientéliste
bon euh je peux pas le dire comme ça
parce que le point d' indice était
bloqué depuis 6 ans et je considère que
c'est pas normal et que c'est pas juste
donc de ce point de vue-là je n'ai pas
classé cette mesure dans les mesures
clientélistes mais les autres qu'on voit
se multiplier jour après jour en
direction des jeunes sans emploi en
direction de telle ou telle catégorie de
la fonction publique oui c'est
clientélistes euh pour ma part je pense
que ça ne marchera pas parce que le
sentiment qui fait que des citoyens se
prononc pour choisir un président de la
République c'est un mouvement beaucoup
plus profond et qui ne répond pas à des
à des choses aussi grossières alors
justement Christophe jacubissine sur ce
point oui quelques mois après son
accession à l'Élysée vous aviez dit à
François Hollande tu es mort vous le
pensez toujours aujourd'hui ça c'est
vous qui l'avez écrit c'est pas moi qui
l' c'est vous qui n l'avez dit donc
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous le
pensez toujours ah oui moi je pense que
François Hollande a
perdu une très grande partie des 5
années qui lui étaient alloué et en même
temps ses chances parce que il n'a pas
osé voulu faire les choix qu'il devait
faire s'adresser au pays comme il devait
s'adresser à lui c'est quelqu'un
de d' inelligent du point de vue de de
la souplesse de l'esprit c'est quelqu'un
d'agréable enfin de Jovial de tout cela
nous le savons c'est quelqu'un qui
n'assume pas n'assume pas la
responsabilité qui n'assume pas comme il
devrait le faire la responsabilité de
président de la républque mais estce
qu'il devrait renoncer à une nouvelle
candidature est-ce que vous pensez
renoncera pas il ira vous voyez bien que
tous les jours montre que il est en
route pour se présenter mais mais je
veux je
vais reprendre une phrase que que j'ai
déjà dite dans des interviews sur ce
sujet il se comporte comme si la
fonction de Président de la République
était une fonction politique comme celle
de premier secrétaire du PS or c'est une
fonction historique c'est-à-dire qu'il a
la responsabilité la charge le président
de la République a ou devrait avoir la
responsabilité et la charge de montrer
un chemin à son pays il jamais de de non
il n'a jamais endossé ce rôle à un point
caricatural parce que on a eu la crise
de la Grèce il a pas dit un mot pendant
la crise de la Grèce on a actuellement
la crise de l'Europe il ne dit pas un
mot sur la crise de l'Europe on a eu
toutes les difficultés que nous savons
s'expriment pas donc il est toujours pas
à la hauteur pour vous ce président et
donc un euh et deux il se comporte comme
si c'était un prolongement de la
fonction de premier secrétaire du PS
mais ce qu'on attend d'un président de
la République ce que moi j'attends en
tout cas c'est qu'il monte au-dessus des
intérêts partisans au-dessus des
intérêts de clan qu'il se sent en charge
de tout le pays et pas seulement de ses
amis
COP pourquoi il pourquoi il ne le fait
pas bah peut-être parce que il il n'a
pas le cette disposition d'esprit là
peut-être parce qu'il il n'envisage pas
sa sa fonction sous cet angle peut-être
parce que depuis longtemps il est pris
dans le jeu et c'est un jeu hélas
nuisible des rapports de force
entrecourants au sein de la gauche ce
dont honnêtement le pays devrait se
ficher et perdumond le pays il devrait
avoir en
tête
le les questions qui engage son histoire
c'est-à-dire comment on va relever le
défi de la mondialisation
comment va-t-on faire pour que notre
identité nationale notre notre culture
notre langue est un avenir et pas
seulement du passé comment va-t-on faire
pour qu'en France le sentiment de
de vivre ensemble de société que nous
devons faire ensemble se renforce au
lieu de se dissoudre comment devons-nous
faire pour que ce c'est tout un
programme pour une élection
présidentielle ça François Baou
ouut je suis en train de vous enfin de
développer devant vous la vision que
j'ai de la fonction et du moment
historique que nous sommes en train de
VI qu'elle est toujours incarné cette
vision par Alain Jupé que vous soutenez
pour la primaire de la droite ou est-ce
que vous estimez que quand vous entendez
son discours on dit qu'il se droitise un
peu par exemple sur les questions
d'autorité est-ce que vous dites et ben
je ne suis pas sûr de le suivre jusqu'au
bout vous je ne sais pas mais moi quand
j'ai pris une orientation euh je cette
orientation je la défends parce que je
ne la prends pas à la légère vous êtes
dans ce choix CZ que la primaire de
droitise tous les candidats y compris
donc à la JP alors je vais je vais
revenir à ce point euh pourquoi est-ce
que je soutiens Alain Jupé parce que
c'est alors d'abord parce que j'ai
confiance en lui je le connais depuis
euh des années nous avons exercé des
fonctions symétriqu
ensemble il était secrétaire général du
RPR j'étais secrétaire général de l'UDF
jeune tous les
deux et j'ai confiance en lui j'ai
confiance sur la rapidité des réformesou
vous dites que sur le rythme visiblement
vous vous êtes pour des réformes quand
même rapides après l'élection lui est
plutôt sur un rythme plus lent qu'un
kénal
alors je ne suis pas en train de vous
dire que j'ai ent les mêmes idées
qu'alin Jupé sur tous les sujets ça ne
serait pas vrai h et j'ai bien
l'intention s'il est choisi ou quand il
sera choisi d'être auprès de lui de ceux
qui le font bouger son d'être son
aiguillon de de de
garantir le fait que peut-être
interviendront des
changements des pratiques différentes
parce que il est intelligent il
comprendra cette nécessité donc je n'ai
pas les mêmes idées décoli mais j'ai
confiance en lui en lui comme personne
et pour une raison que j'ajoute et je
m'arrêterai là sur lui c'est que c'est
le seul qui est annoncé qu'il ne serait
pas pour sa majorité future prisonnier
des partis ce qui vous permettre à vous
d'être éventuellement central comme vous
souhaitez l'être dans une majorité
franchement j'espère que vous allez me
croire je sais bien que que c'est le jeu
mais je vous assure que je ne pense pas
à cette échéance au travers de mon
intérêt personnel si j'y pensais au
travers de mon intérêt personnel
j'aurais regardé les sondages qui sont
flatteurs hein qui sont assez haut en
socle électoral 12 % à peu près 14 si
c'est donc vous les connaissez bien ce
que ça pourrait jouer
justement quand vous partez avec un sole
de 14 % alors que le Président de la
République sortant est à 16 parfois vous
avez une capacité d'action de conviction
de
confiance donc je réponds clairement à
la question que vous avez posé je ne
pense pas à cette échéance en intérêt
personnel d'accord mais est-ce que vous
pensez que Alain Jup peut gagner cette
primaire vous aviez souvent dit jusque
là que la primaire de la droite était
sur le noyau dur des militants et qu'il
avait peu de chance de l'emporter est-ce
que votre est en train de changer cette
dernière partie de la phrase c'est vous
qui l' dit et pas moi je redoute la
primaire je redoute le mécanisme de la
primaire et quand je le vois se vouz on
va en parler sous nos yeux je suis pas
rassuré parce qu'on assure on assiste à
une course à la surenchère euh par
exemple Monsieur Bruno Le Maire oui a
déclaré cette semaine sans que un s'il
ne bouge que il exigeait que il
exigerait que désormais l'administration
puisse avoir accès au compte bancaires
des personnes qui reçoivent le RSA mais
si comme ça
est-ce est-ce que vous trouvez ça
choquant c'est pour moi je vous ai parlé
tout tout à l'heure
de du sentiment qui est le mien de
responsabilité à l'égard de ceux qui
n'ont ni le pouvoir ni l'argent ni les
relation je trouve que cette cette
déclaration n'est-ce pas il a pas
demandé qu'on aille voir les comptes
bancaires de ceux qui ont des comptes au
Panama il a pas demandé qu'on aille voir
les comptes bancaires des situations les
plus
dans la société française il veut qu'on
aille mener une œuvre d'inquisition sur
les pauvres gens qui touchent le r Je ne
suis pas je ne suis pas sur cette
ligne la société française qui demande
plus de contrôle sur la sistana et qui
est souvent très opposé à à des des
allocations qu'elle considèreent souvent
comme
excessive monsieur ro celui qui vient en
face de moi et qui qui me dit que le RSA
c'est excessif celui-là excusez-moi il
vit pas dans le même monde que moi pour
un certain nombre d'allocataires pour
pour un certain nombre d'allocatair
parce que vous savez ce que c'est le RSA
oui vous savez quel est le niveau du RSA
socle et vous pensez qu'avec les
quelques centaines d'euros que ça
apporte on est dans l'abondance les an
c'est mais dans quel monde vivez-vous je
on n de viv les gens qui disent cela moi
en tout cas jamais je ne inscrirait dans
cette ligne là est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a une surenchè populiste dans
cette primaire monsieur ba justement
c'est c'est le fonctionnement-moi de de
répéter ce que j'ai dit le la logique de
la primaire c'est la surenchère ça
conduit à ça je l'ai dit depuis le début
j'ai essayé c'est pas un secret de
convaincre à Jupé de ne paser fatale
alin Jupé est-ce que vous pensez que ça
peut l'être encore le pire c'est que ces
idéesl elles sont pas fatales à un
candidat ou à un autre elles sont
fatales à à l'idée que nous devons nous
faire de notre pays et de son avenir
vous comprenez ça le le fait que qu'on
stigmatise qu'on montre qu'on désigne
telle ou telle catégorie de Français le
que ce soit les mêmes qui disent on va
supprimer la fonction publique
territoriale je suis à la tête d'une
d'une ville et d'une agglomération je
reçois une fois par mois directement
sans rendez-vous pendant des heures je
l'ai fait hier matin tous les euh
employés de la Ville qui souhaite me
rencontrer vous savez et je demande à
chacun combien il gagne net vous savez
combien on gagne net en catégorie C ce
que ce que Monsieur le Maire désigne
comme des privilégié on gagne 1200 1250
1300 et ils me disent 1348
€ la rémunération et bien moi en tout
cas cette manière de cibler une partie
des Français pour faire plaisir à une
catégorie deélectorat écoutez-moi bien
c'est le contraire non pas de ce que je
pense c'est le contraire de ce que je
suis mais est-ce que vous pensez c'est
le contraire c'est le contraire de mes
raisons de vivre de ma manière de
regarder regarder vous PZ qu'il pas les
rapports humains dans le pays gu est-ce
que vous pensez que dans ce contexte là
Jup a quand même ses chances est-ce que
vous avez des craintes sur sa victoire
excusez-moi je pense qu'il a ses chances
et je l'aiderai mais ça n'est pas le
sujet bah si parce que vous seriez
derrière lui si jamais c'est pas le cas
vous nous confirmez que vous y allezj
non le sujet c'est beaucoup plus profond
que cela et que ce que vous dites je
pense qu'il y a des problèmes avec le
RSA je vais vous en citer un il y a une
situation enfin il y a une réalité qui
est pour moi
extrêmement nuisible
c'est que un certain nombre de femmes et
d'hommes dans la situation du RSA en
accumulant des allocations n'ont pas
intérêt à reprendre un travail parce que
H HM reprenant un travail on leur coupe
un certain nombre d'aides d'allocation
ça n'est donc pas incitatif je suis tout
à fait prêt à regarder ça mais pas à
prendre l'air méprisant la morgue et la
mou de celui qui dit
assistana fin de tout ça parce que on
voit bien qu'il connaissent pas les gens
dans une situation comme C souci à
suivre votre raisonnement j'ai du mal à
à comprendre comment vous considiliez ce
que vous venez nous dire là maintenant
et le fait que vous régulièrement vous
dites que il doit y avoir une rupture
franche au moment de en 2017 du du
changement de pouvoir ça veut dire quoi
c'est quoi une rupture franche lorsque
comme vous on est soucieux on l'a
entendu des
équilibres des plus défavorisés des plus
FA faible oh ben c'est très simple euh
la rupture franche elle suppose que ça
n'est plus des groupes d'intérêts qui
pèse dans l'ombre pour diriger les
décisions du pays elle suppose qu'on va
se mettre à bien gérer je vais prendre
un exemple très simple et quel groupe
d'intérêt là par ou EDF euh le ce groupe
là grand groupe national est me
semble-t-il menacé si ce n'est au bord
d'une catastrophe financière et
industrielle sans précédent peut-être
faudrait-il remonter jusqu'au Crédit
Lyonnais pour y arriver on est dans la
situation où EDF est engagé pour des
centaines de milliards sur plusieurs
chapitres d'abord il a plus de 30
milliards de dettes il a 90 milliards
d'engagements sur ses retraites mais
vous êtes voir une recapitalisation par
l'État ou pas
attendez laissez-moi poursuivre ceux qui
nous écoutent ne savent pas ce que je
suis en train de dire parce qu'on le dit
pas ù ça passe tellement
inaperçu ensuite il y a les engagements
ils sont supérieurs à 100 milliards s'il
faut démanteler ou quand il faudra
démanteler les centrales nucléaires vous
pensez qu'il faut pas dé comm DITC s
aujourd'hui non mais une Parè non mais
vous voulez pas qu'on aille au bout des
phrases c'est quand même beaucoup plus
simple qu'on puisse aller au bout des
phrases j'en étais à plus de 100
milliards pour le démantellement il y a
plusieurs dizaines de milliards pour la
remise à niveau il y a les engagements
que nous avons pour construire des pr
dont on sait pas si on sait les faire
marcher NOTAM au Roumi donc la question
c'est ça aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on
renonce à ce projetve et on arrive à des
centaines de milliards d'engagements et
je pense qu'il serait nécessaire que la
puissance publique rupture comme vous le
dites exige la transparence sur par
exemple en organisant sous le contrôle
du Parlement un audit financier un audit
technologique et un audit stratégique
vous croyez que c'est un créditonis en
puissance EDF oui je pense que EDF est
dans une situation inquiétante et je
pense que si elle est dans une situation
inquiétante c'est parce que l'État n'a
pas fait son boulot et vous
m'interrogiez sur le type de rupture que
je trouve nécessaire celui-là est une
rupture nécessaire quand l'État est
propriétaire d'une entreprise il ne il
ne doit pas être prisonnier de de des
sentiments qu'il porte à tel ou tel
dirigeant qui le met dans sa poche et ça
rend les gens ce sont des grandes
entreprises qui rendent les gens un peu
fou hein toute cette affaire tous ces
engagements qui ont été pris l'État
aurait dû être là pour dire pour dire
excusez-moi ça n'est pas possible
et dans le dans le dans la situation du
pays il y a l'exigence d'une rupture
franche sur la manière dont on le
gouverne la gouvernance François Baou on
va accueillir benoî galeré qui va nous
communiquer les questions bonus hein des
des téléspectateurs et auditeurs qui
nous qui vous écoutent depuis presque
trois quart d'heure maintenant Benoît
que disent ceux qui nous entendent
bonjour certains s'inquiètent pour le
centre il pensaient que vous alliez
révéler aujourd'hui que vous étiez
candidat finalement que vous changiez
d'avis Charles vous demande quel est
l'état de vos relations avec l'UDI et
notamment son président bon alors je je
vais je vais répondre à la question
parce que après tout c'est très simple
hein
j'ai dit que si Alain jupet était choisi
je le soutiendrai et si Alain Jupé n'est
pas choisi j'exercerai ma liberté vous
irez j'exercerai ma liberté mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire j'exercerai
ma liberté mon c'est très simple je je
je ferai les choix nécessaires pour que
ce que je crois précieux pour l'avenir
du pays soit représenté dans l'élection
présidentielle et non seulement
représenté mais entendu et soutenu par
les français pour pourquoi aujourd'hui
le discours clair d'un homme politique
comme vous ce ne serait pas de dire oui
j'irai je ser candidat parce que je n'ai
pas envie de vous fournir un titre ah
mais c'est pas un titre c'est est-ce que
ça fait pas partie aussi de ce
discoursp c'est une je reporte pas les
décisions je vous ai dit que si que mon
soutien allait à à l'in Jupé et à lui
seul et si Nicolas chois je n'ai aucun
je n'aurai aucun engagement de cet autre
avec quelqu autre candidat que ce soit
parce que je considère que ce qui est en
jeu c'est beaucoup plus important que
des rapports de forces politiqu c'est un
pays qui est au bord de de de de
l'effondrement sur lui-même par moment
donc vous ne fmez pas complètement la
porte j'ai donc la r
questionoiz-vous tous les plateaux si
vous nêtes candidat à rien et ben là sa
réponse c'est socialand qui n'a pas
l'air d'aimer François Hollanda a priori
qui persciifle je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais François Baayou soutient
toujours celui qui est le mieux placé
pour les présidentiells ça n'a pas
marché à gauche di Onix hop demi-tour à
droite avec Papi Jupé est-ce que vous
avez est-ce que est-ce que ce est-ce que
cet auditeur se se souvient de 2007 de
je pas le souvenir d'avoir soutenu
toujours le mieux placé alors on va le
çaétait un peu parf par contra est-ce
que vous cigz pas qu'on vous fasse ce
procès là de changer au gré des
circonstances c'estàdire d'avoir change
en rien aujourd'hui la droite je ne
change en rien au gré des
circonstances il se trouve que François
Hollande a
abandonné les promesses qu'il avait
faites et ceux qui le
soutenaient il avait promis de changer
la vie politique du pays il ne l'a pas
fait il avait promis de baisser les
déficits il ne l'a pas fait il avait
promis de faire baisser le chômage il ne
l'a pas fait fait il avait promis de
donner aux entreprises un un un statut
solide dans l'entreprise il ne l'a pas
fait et comme il a abandonner ses
promesses moi je maintiens le cap que
j'ai
choisi F contre lui Jupé n'a pas plus de
solution ne pourriez-vous pas plutôt
avoir un vrai programme à vous et le
défendre il faut bien c'est c'est ce que
je viens de faire je ne crois pas que je
sois de ce point de vue-là voyez et
quand vous voyez un Emmanuel Macron qui
serait un nouveau giscardien pour pour
Jean-Pierre
qui n'est ni de gauche ni de droite
comme vous ah non non non non non pas du
tout alors rien à voir alors je vais
essayer de vous expliquer pourquoi
encore encore voilà encore que ce ne
soit pas si simple d'abord moi je ne
sais pas qui est Emmanuel Macron bah
comment ça se fait tout le monde en
parleoui c'est pas parce que les gens en
parlent vous devriez savoir c'est votre
métier c'est pas parce qu'on parle des
choses moi je ne sais pas qui il est je
n'ai il dit des choses vagues et son
action au gouvernement ne me me paraît
pas tranchée ou différente de celle du
gouvernement actuel je rappelle qu'il
est ministre de
l'Économie ce que j'ai dit sur EDF là ça
dépend du ministère de l'Économie où je
me oui mais il veut dépasser les
clivages monsieur Baou comme vous vous
souhaitez le faire depuis 20 ans et bien
vous vous trompez sur la
l'idée que je me fais de cette affaire
il se trouve que je n'ai jamais dit je
crois qu'on aura du mal à trouver des
citations on peut en chercher mais je
n'ai pas envie de me définir par une
double négation euh ni d'un camp ni de
l'autre j'ai deux affirmations la
première c'est
que vouloir résumer la vie politique
française à deux camp à ce monopole à
deux qu'exerce alternativement le PS et
l'UMP c'est le contraire de l'intérêt
national et le contraire de la réalité
du
pays moi je suis pour le
pluralisme je p est-ce
que
etinre affirm en tout cas jete le
drapeau de l'un d'entre eux deuxième
affirmation qui est le courant du centre
si ce courant qui a une base extrêmement
importante qui représente une attente
dans le pays si ce courant existait il
jouerait un rôle majeur la faiblesse des
hommes a fait que il se il passent leur
viemu peut pas incarner ce centre là
Macron il n'est pas inscrit est-ce que
vous ne cigz pas françisou très
franchement qu'il ringardise toute une
partie de la classe politique française
et notamment vous qui êtes dans le
système politique depuis un certain
temps est-ce que c'est pas la crainte de
tous ceux qui sont installés
euh franchement si si vous imaginez que
ça représente une crainte de voir des
expressions politiques nouvelles
arrivriver c'est que vous n'êtes pas un
responsable politique ou un homme
polique par un duel Macron le maire la
présidentielle
formidable et je vous assure que ça ne
suscite pas de l'envie chez un grand
nombre de Français dont je vousêêtes sûr
regardez des des sondages c'est pas une
deux dernières questions monsieur Baou
on va devoir se quitter sur Nicolas
Sarkozi comment qualifieriez-vous la
ligne qu'il a adopté dans cette
précampagne qui ne dit pas son nom cette
ligne est très simple Nicolas Sarkozy a
compris comment marche une primaire il
s'adresse à l'électoral le plus le noyau
dur de l'électorat qui dont il pense
qu'il va aller aux urnes et il va dans
son sens mais vous avez compris ce que
dit Nicolas Sarkozi qui est une attaque
contre
Jupé en fait
c'est il faut que la droite soit
vraiment à droite et la gauche vraiment
à gauche et que et c'est ça la
démocratie j'ajoute moi que s'il faut
une droite et une gauche alors il faut
un
centre il faut un centre ou puissant
rassemblé qui sache ce qu'il pense et
qui n'it peur de rien vous entend est-ce
que vous cz monsieur Baou avant qu'on se
quitte que Marine Le Pen soit sa au
second tour d'élection présidentielle
pour vous est-ce que c'est une certitude
bah ça on verra dans les élections il y
a pas de certitude avant une élection
c'est une probabilité une possibilité
une probabilité et cette probabilité
n'est pas à mes yeux heureuse pour la
France merci beaucoup monsieur Baayou
c'était votre grand je merci à tous les
trois vous pouvez retrouver l'émission
Ce soir sur LCI de 18h30 à 19h30 et les
meilleurs extraits sur RTL vers 18h15
bon premier mai à tous à très bientôt so